All right.
So we're going to move on
to a different category.
And we're going to
go in this order.
And then at the end,
we're going to have
a little more depth about the
Social Innovation project.
So I love this project.
It's the project
that when everyone
says to me what is
curriculum mapping,
it's the one that I bring up
because it's just so clear.
If you said across
the university,
what are all of the
courses, all the ways
that ethics is being taught?
It's probably taught in
every Harvard school.
How do we know where are
the ethics courses are?
So the team, which
you can see here--
Danielle Allen couldn't be here.
Jess Miner, Michael
Blau, David Comer Kidd.
They have been
working really hard.
And as I understand it, you took
kind of inductive and deductive
approaches both to narrowing
in on the range of many words
that could be related
to ethics instruction.
And then you used
that to develop
a kind of weighted
algorithm, and then used
that weighted algorithm to
search all of the syllabi,
and then to identify courses.
Survey instructors
get their teaching
learning materials
that then become
additional sources of data to
draw out the implicit learning
theories around ethics and
to begin to think about not
just which courses,
but the pedagogical
approaches to teaching
ethics, and how
to develop a community
here around those issues,
and then broaden that
community outside of Harvard
and think about
ethics instruction
out there in the world
and in other institutions.
So key constituents,
undergraduate and professional
students, faculty, instructors,
and administrators.
That's the whole university.
I think you could add alumni.
And I do think it does have
that sort of applicability.
So look at this visual, how
many courses were identified.
That's a lot of courses.
Then there is how many
were selected out of that
and unique instructors.
And look at how many
survey responses they got.
This is already a community.
By next year the goal is to
do another round of faculty
surveys, refine and
administer the pre-
and post-semester student
surveys, so now learning
from students, and test and
transfer the methodology
to other campuses, and
hopes for curriculum
mapping it at Harvard.
Build student-friendly tools
for identifying ethics courses
and learning opportunities.
What do student-friendly
tools look like?
We'll be getting
to that because I
think Jeffrey and others
in the Curricle project
are also thinking about
student-friendly kinds
of tools.
Identify strengths and gaps in
ethics education at Harvard.
Promote discussion
and collaboration.
Similarly, Subu, faculty member
in the School of Public Health,
had another kind of question
that was crossing instruction
all across Harvard.
Who's teaching applied
quantitative methods?
What are the applied
statistics courses
that are being taught in social
sciences by non-statisticians?
How do these courses compare?
How do students move through
the system to take courses
in applied statistics?
And people do move.
They don't just stick
in their school.
They move to other
schools to try
to get the methodological
training that they
feel that they need.
Graduate students are the
key constituency here,
and then faculty.
By next year have a web resource
to facilitate optimal course
selection for students.
A synthesis-based
deep dive of what's
being taught at
Harvard with an aim
to develop a taxonomy
of these courses.
That's a big goal.
It should be an interesting one.
And again, it will be drawing
on the data sources of syllabi
and course materials.
Subu or Judy might
remember as we identified
these courses, reached
out to faculty and said,
hey, could you send
us our syllabi,
because we couldn't use
syllabus tool because it was not
just in the FAS.
Within an hour, you
had hundreds of people,
or a whole lot of
people writing.
There is a hunger
among the faculty
to be able to share their
resources with one another
and to build this
kind of community.
So one of the goals is just
making this meaningful faculty
connections, and then providing
more course selection support
to students.
If you look at this
visual, you can
see the percentage of the
applied quantitative methods
by school.
But we don't know if
this picture is accurate.
We really don't know.
I think this is a
first stab, and then we
have to iterate and
learn to what degree this
might change over time.
So Curricle is this amazing
intellectual project.
And when I first heard about
it, my jaw almost dropped.
I really couldn't believe
that this ambitious effort
was underway.
We have Jeffrey, Matthew
Battles couldn't be here.
Sebastian.
We have Jessica, Kim
here from the team.
And you can see here we've
got these two different.
They're both doing user testing
and still collecting data.
As I have thought
about this project,
there's sort of two parts of it.
One is building a
curiosity-driven search
tool for students.
And the other is drawing
on really interesting
archival data about the
intellectual curricular
story of Harvard
over time, going back
the hundreds of
years of the things
that have been taught
at Harvard to say, how
has Dante's Inferno been taught
throughout Harvard's history,
and to develop these kinds
of stories of a student's
progression while
they were here that
might get students to think
in different kinds of ways
than they usually do about
their own progression and path
through the curriculum.
So I think it's an ambitious
project because there's
a lot of data that might not
be digitized and easily put
into a format where you could
do that kind of deep work.
At the same time, it really
relates to a lot of the tools
that Dustin has been building.
And as we, in a more
straightforward way,
are building these tools
and increasing data sources,
we can pull it together
with the things
that Jeffrey and others
have been working on.
So research questions.
How might data visualization
reveal hidden connections
among courses of study?
How might we provide students
with meaningful data in a user
friendly format to support
them in course selection?
Using and adapting
historical curriculum data,
what stories can we tell about
intellectual and curricular
trends throughout
Harvard's history?
Students, faculty, department
chairs as key constituents.
Goals by June 2019.
One full academic year of public
prototype testing completed.
I think-- tell me if
this is right-- you're
in prototype testing now.
Yeah.
Suite visualization
micronarratives
published and a mobile
version in demo.
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard.
Visualization and
data integration
will promote discovery
and course selection.
Visualizations can
show connections.
Now how in the world--
I was looking at this
visual and I was like, wait.
Are these the schools that
tell the truth, and these
are the schools that are--
and so I had to get
some clarification.
No.
This tool allows you
to put in any two words
and then see which
schools have courses
that offer things related
to those words overlapping.
And then if you click on
one of those in the middle--
this is already in an interface,
a tool that you can play with--
then you get to actually
see all the list of courses
and the ways in which they're
talking about either truth
or lie.
All right.
DART.
I cannot do this
project justice.
I think you can't do it
justice in this sort of format.
What you need to do is actually
play with this and have a demo.
You need to go and look at this.
There's a website,
and I should just
say on the little brochures we
handed out, there's a website.
You can go and learn more
information about these tools.
Also you can go and look
up DART in particular.
So imagine this
repository where you
can put teaching and learning
assets of any number of sizes
and shapes.
Right now the
content has started
with HarvardX data, HarvardX
videos and other assets that
are in HarvardX courses, as
well as Harvard YouTube video
assets.
But it could include any
kinds of teaching and learning
assets.
And then it's this really
powerful search tool.
So you use search for a word
that you're interested in.
I think the demos I've
seen have been like moon.
And all of the things that
are related to moon come up.
And you can do a little
preview really quickly
of what these things look like.
Then, most magically,
you just say
I want to put this
in my Canvas course.
Boom.
It's in your Canvas course,
and you can use it and share it
with your students.
So it is a work in
progress right now.
As I understand it,
the more that Daniel
can get people to use
it and give feedback,
the more he can build new
attributes and new tools.
So you should talk with Daniel.
You should play with it and
you should talk with Daniel,
and you should begin to see
what else he can do to help you
use this tool more over time.
By June 2019,
cross-institutional content
sharing and more direct
reuse of Canvas resources.
So now it's going
the other direction.
You have Canvas resources.
Make it usable for
everybody to then put
into their Canvas courses.
This is what the
interface looks like.
Hopes for curriculum
mapping at Harvard.
Provide data and
tools that allow
people to more directly
explore Harvard content.
We're going to now
hear from Brittany
for this last of our
curriculum mapping projects.